[Music]
welcome to waters world i'm jesse waters
too little too late that's the subject
of tonight's waters words
biden's in his first year and already a
lame duck the country doesn't trust him
or respect him we watch him react to
problems like he's intoxicated sloppy
careless and slow americans are
suffering people's lives are harder not
easier biden and the people around them
are so out of touch with reality they're
living in a fantasy land where if they
say things are fine the media is just
going to repeat it and they can go back
to bed
but the media isn't repeating biden's
lies as much as they used to
violent crime is up
murder is way up almost 30 percent
supply chain gridlock and its growing
economic toll quarter of a million
shipping containers remain stuck at seed
you're seeing food and gas prices
skyrocket
chaos at airports nationwide southwest
airlines forced to cancel nearly 2 000
flights the nightmare before halloween
major shortages on everything from
costumes to candy
biden said months ago inflation's just
gonna go away don't worry about it
right now
our experts believe the major
independent forecasters agree as well
that these bottlenecks and price spikes
will reduce as our economy continues to
heal
but they're getting worse prices are up
on everything food furniture especially
gas americans have had enough
it's too long
it's like a whole day's peck almost just
going in glass
not working it's kind of one of those
things you know that
if you're traveling you know you need
it's kind of like a necessity just like
water i'm going to happen in the city
i fill up my truck almost
every day eighty dollars this morning
now another sixty dollars here joe
biden's ruining the country paying 5 39
for super in my car every time i fill it
up when trump was in office it was about
i want to say 45 to 50 dollars
now on empty it takes me about 120 to
fill up the car it's ridiculous it's
breaking everybody's banks
but some outlets are debasing themselves
to protect the president here's the
washington post probably the worst paper
in america
probably on the white house payroll
ready america needs higher longer
lasting inflation
they hate the people of this country
that's clear
christmas is going to be a mess because
people can't get presents u.s ports are
gridlocked in l.a and long beach ports
are massively backlogged all of the
products we have made in china nowadays
we have to rely on them for everything
so when
everything is made in china it takes
forever for the products to get here
biden and his buddies put the factories
there and now we're crunched
this is expected to last past the end of
the year
across the country hundreds and hundreds
of cargo ships just waiting to drop off
their items not enough truck drivers to
drive the product to market either
and you know why this is happening we're
at this point because the unemployment
rate has come down and been cut in half
because
because people are buying more goods
because people are traveling and because
demand is up and because the economy is
turning back on
don't you get it nothing is working
because the biden economy is so great
that's their talking point just like
afghanistan nothing but a success
high prices and empty shelves that's a
sign of progress
but that's not what biden thought when
trump was in charge
we don't have a food shortage problem
we have a leadership problem
we have plenty of food
don't you rubes get it
nothing to do with the free biden bucks
and the mandates causing labor shortages
americans are getting fired quitting and
companies can't hire anybody
but biden blamed you instead
if the private sector doesn't step up
we're going to call them out and ask
them to act
because our goal is not only to get
through this immediate bottleneck but to
address the long-standing weaknesses in
our transportation supply chain that
this pandemic has exposed
it's all our fault
just like he blames the police the board
of patrol or the people he left behind
in afghanistan the buck doesn't stop at
biden that's for sure and we can't fly
either southwest airlines seeing
thousands of flights delayed or canceled
since last weekend and they expect it to
last through the holidays pilots and
staff are protesting biden's vax mandate
and the southwest ceo said he doesn't
even want to do the mandate but he has
to because the president forced his hand
biden is doing absolutely nothing to
stop the crime wave and now in places
like seattle and l.a huge portion of
police officers could very well get laid
off for refusing the vax mandate
that's not going to keep americans safe
and while the problems continue to pile
up like crazy vp kamala harris has been
up to basically nothing but this
a nasa space video with kids to try to
make herself look relatable
to think about so much that's out there
that we still have to learn
like i love that i love that and so i'm
very excited about the space council
you're gonna literally see the craters
on the moon with your own eyes
with your own eyes i'm telling you it is
gonna be
unbelievable
those weren't real kids those were hired
child actors
the company was canadian she didn't even
use an american company
and the company is called sinking ship
productions
you can't make this stuff up
telling your children you couldn't get
the one special present they put on
their christmas list under the tree on
time the pain when you look at the
receipt after filling up your gas tank
the agony of being stranded at an
airport after another canceled flight
biden doesn't care he's not even doing
anything to show he cares like a
low-grade politician would
the buy administration checked out they
lost the room creating a distance bigger
than ever before between the american
people and the presidency
fake white house sets paid actors spin
lies
the white house chief of staff called
high prices high class problems
they're disrespecting you
so what are you going to do about it hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else